hey let's talk about something we can
both relate to because we don't live too
far from each other
a lot of wildfires right now in our part
of
california are you worried do you worry
about the fires are you prepared
well of course i worry about the fires
why wouldn't i worry about the fires
well it's a question i was told to ask
you i thought you had a comedy bit
ready to go so um that's why i asked
well even if you didn't ask i would tell
you that i'm worried about the fires
we we are prepared we have all kinds of
evacuation kits in our garage we have
earthquake
evacuation kits we have fire evacuation
kits we have
covid and by the way any one of these
evacuation kits
will work in a pinch if i have an
argument with my wife
and i get kicked out of the house i just
grab one of them
you can grab so you're saying if if you
have to suddenly leave your wife because
of a fight
you could grab an earthquake a covid or
a fire evacuation kit and just check
into a motel
yeah fire would be better because that
has a tent in it and i wouldn't
so if i see you if i'm driving around
the neighborhood and i see you in a tent
on the front yard
and yet there's been no fires i know
that you've had a fight with your wife
yeah and here's the thing also about the
the i wouldn't take the evacuation kit
because
i've been dipping into that like only
during like
tremors if there's a tremor i'll just
open up and take one little thing out
and
eat it as an emotional
you know blanket a feeling of security
yeah
yeah so um the only thing left in the
evacuation
in the earthquake kit i think it's just
like a can of tuna
white tuna and no can opener right i bet
no can opener ate that
last week